[Musique]
merci à vous et en fait il ya plus d'un
lien qu'on pourrait trouver avec la
présentation aux précédentes notamment
celle de la dualité dans l'internet
cette double face ouailles et qu'il y
avait deux clés de lecture sur cette
même musique qui pour certains est
porteuse de promesses et merveilleux et
pour doter de la cacophonie lors sur
internet c'est un peu la même chose et
on va s'intéresser à cette prise de
conscience que nous avons de prendre un
risque ou non en allant sur internet
quand on se connecte à internet qu'on
réalise des activités sur internet
alors pour comprendre cette prise de
risque il faut comprendre le monde dans
lequel nous vivons et cet écosystème
numérique que nous avons construit que
nous continuons à construire en donnant
de données en utilisant les services
alors que veut dire cette hyper
connectivité et je pense aussi comme
vous l'avait fait précédemment monsieur
c'est de rappeler cette évolution
historique dans lequel nous sommes tous
des héritiers d'histoire et un test
histoire de l'informatique on va faire
très court mais je retiendrai plusieurs
dates
la première c'est qui nous est peut-être
plus familière c'est la seconde guerre
mondiale où on a vu l'émergence de
l'informatique avec d un besoin de
computation de calcul informatique pour
briser des codes et demi et c'est grâce
à alan turing qui a fait naître cette
informatique moderne et on est dans un
contexte de guerre qui dit guerre c'est
défense des territoires de complète des
territoires préservation des valeurs la
deuxième référence historique je
voudrais faire c'est celle de l'internet
que ce merveilleux outil de
communication que nous connaissons qui
lui aussi est qu est né dans un contexte
de guerre du département de la défense
américain où on parlait c'était l'époque
de la guerre froide et la troisième
référence technologique que nous
utilisons aussi est qui et qui est le
fruit de cette évolution mais cet esprit
de conquête et de maîtrise
c'est le gps que nous utilisons dans la
vie de tous les jours et qui est un
outil pour faire la guerre qui a été
conçu pour gagner des guerres pour être
dans la performance de la guerre alors
pourquoi ces trois références c'est bien
pour comprendre aussi prôné dans cet
esprit de conquête des territoires et on
aurait pu faire la référence aux cils
conquête des maires au 15e au xvième
siècle et la complète des voies
maritimes c'est l'ouverture vers de
nouveaux territoires c'est la
colonisation des territoires pour capter
des valeurs les plus conquérir
de nouvelles opportunités et je crois
qu'avec le numérique nous sommes dans ce
contexte là dans cette même philosophie
de conquête des territoires numériques
et que sont nos territoires numériques
sont nos patrimoine numérique ce sont
des données
alors on est dans cet esprit de conquête
de guerre de préservation puis je crois
qu'on est tous aussi conscient qu'on
vivons une crise économique qui est là
pour durer et je ne suis pas sûr que les
ceux qui sont nés au 21ème siècle ne
connaisse autre chose qu'un contexte de
guerre économique exacerbée
donc nous sommes dans cet environnement
de la connexion et de la connexion qui
devient de plus en plus permanent
pourquoi puisqu'on a compris au 21ème
siècle que la valeur de société
la valeur qui avaient de l'argent
s'était pas l'or mais c'était
l'information sur l'or donc toute cette
information est devenu le capital le
nerf de la guerre si vous voulez et donc
là on a vu se développer des services et
une économie du numérique est basée sur
l'exploitation des données sur du sur la
consommation de données et l'idée c'est
de pouvoir capter en permanence des
données et pouvoir les traiter et
inciter les personnes à être connecté en
permanence alors nous sommes de plus en
plus connecté vous en faites sans doute
l'expérience dans votre vie
professionnelle ou votre vie privée
j'ai envie de dire même les vaches sont
connectées sont à l'heureux j'en suis
pas sûr et les animaux sauvages ont été
les premiers à être connectés et
peut-être le savez vous ce sont les
baleines qui ont été connectées ou puce
et les premières pour pouvoir justement
pouvoir les suivre les traces et et puis
offrir un peu peut-être une idée de
préservation de l'espèce
donc on voit qu'on a cette sollicitation
permanente d'être de plus en plus
connectés pour alimenter cette économie
du numérique d'une économie d'ultra
libéralisme et de l'exploitation des
données donc de consommation
d'exploitation alors dans cette hyper
connectivité qu'est-ce qu'il faut se
souvenir c'est qu'on a on a parlé très
rapidement et très certainement de cette
évolution des techniques informatiques
on pourrait s'intéresser beaucoup plus
aussi sur les interfaces les outils de
communication entre l'homme et la
machine j'ai envie de dire l'humain et
la machine et plus c'est compliqué pour
la machine puis c'est simple pour pour
l'humain et on voit cette simplification
d'accès d'interfaçage qui est ainsi coco
mi-temps à la miniaturisation des
composant est le composant informatique
est devenue tellement minuscule reparle
de poussière intelligente de
nanotechnologies et les cette capacité
embarquée d'avoir des puissances
d'automne d'autonomie en termes
d'énergie permet l'invisibilité des
communications dont on a un fil à la
patte électronique qui est invisible
puisque on communique avec du sans fil
et cette évolution du sans fil a été
aussi favorisée par une évolution des
réglementations liées à l' usage de
l'espace pour communiquer donc on a vu
se dessiner depuis géré la seconde
guerre mondiale la mise en place d'une
infrastructure de thé que
télécommunications on y présente mais de
plus en plus invisibles faut savoir que
les premiers câbles transatlantiques qui
ont servi pour la téléphonie d'un
télégraphiste 1858 donc c'est pas tout à
fait récent mais depuis cette guerre
froide depuis la conquête de l'espace et
on a marché sur la ligne c'était en 1969
on a vu aussi cette conquête de l'espace
avec des satellites de
télécommunications qui permettait à des
civils usage la transmission
d'informations c'est pour ça qu'on a vu
quand même ce premier homme sur la lune
ce mois de juillet 69 alors cette
infrastructure elle est là il y à des
services qui sont possibles du fait des
composants des terminaux d'accès des
contenus on a beaucoup irrité du
multimédia du divertissement et de la
capacité à traiter ces informations
on a vu la miniaturisation des
composants avec des capteurs qui
deviennent de plus en plus minuscule mon
chien est pucé il a une puce rfid dans
le cou j'imagine que moi dans dix ans
j'en aurai une aussi puisque on trouvera
sa mêmes pratiques
alors mon téléphone en fait c'est un
téléphone mais ma voiture c'est un
téléphone dans lequel je peux m'asseoir
kwassa téléphone à roulettes une voiture
on a vu apparaître cet internet des
objets du fait de cette concomitance et
puis cet alignement des étoiles sera en
termes de technologie de maîtrise de
fabrication des composants et puis cette
énergie informationnel qui va nous
alimenter dans cette énergie
informationnel on voit bien qu'on a des
intérêts
economica pouvoir les capter les
maîtriser dans la vue des entreprises
prendre du pouvoir dans ce domaine des
télécoms et de l'informatisation qui des
entreprises dont même le nom sont
devenus des mots du dictionnaire c'est
le cas de google et c'est le cas de
l'ubs et risation de la société on parle
bien du b risation qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est à dire que tout ce qu'on
faisait avant on le fait mais d'une
façon différente
via des plates formes de mise en
relation des plateformes des changes
donc cette communication qu'on veut
extensive avec tout un chacun
c'est une communication qui est médiée
par des technologies de l'information
mais parler des technologies ce n'est
pas suffisant il faudrait parler de ceux
qui conçoivent cette technologie qui les
maîtrisent qui les met en oeuvre qui les
gèrent qui les vendent et puis ceux qui
utilisent donc on est dans cet
écosystème on voit bien qu'on vient
devient de plus en plus dépendants à des
fournisseurs de technologies et à des
solutions de technologies pour le
meilleur et gérer pour le pire alors
dans ce contexte d'hyper connectivité
permanente omniprésente et dans cette
hyper connectivité on voit bien qu'on a
besoin et je reviens à cette conquête
des merdes ces nouveaux territoires de
cartographie des informations la preuve
en est que si vous voulez voir des
images de la lune de mars des fonds
sous-marins vous y avez accès grâce à
vos moteurs de recherche préféré
peut-être on lire dans cette captation
permanente de l'information et on a
évoqué tout à l'heure avec les virus
biologique
on voit bien cet adn c'est joli mais
peut-être que l'adn c'est le premier
système d'information qui a existé avant
même de parler de technologies de
l'information dont il a avec des
capteurs et cette intégration dans le
corps biologique de l'électronique on
est en capacité de capter en permanence
les données du vivant et on parle du
corps mais je vous ai parlé de mon chien
tout à l'heure des vaches connectés eh
bien on élargit ce sens de captation de
la formation non plus à l'être humain ni
aux objets au niveau des techniques mais
au monde du vivant et le système
d'information devient enfin le système
l'adn systèmes d'information du vivant
devient une valeur et marchands du fait
qu'on l'a digitalisées qu'on la connaît
en informatique que ces traités par des
ordinateurs et bien on est dans
dans l'industrie du vivant on a parlé
d'industrie 2.0 2.3 points 0,4 point
zéro et là on est dans du 5.0 c'est
l'industrie du vivant et on voit que si
on considère que la formation comme une
valeur marchande
tout est à vendre sur internet et tout
et vandam sur internet et toute notre
représentation du monde médiation du
monde via des technologies qui va se
résumer par du des informations codées
en binaire traités par des algorithmes
et des ordinateurs qui font du
traitement algorithmique et du
traitement avec des opérations
arithmétiques est logique
donc on voit aussi cette règle réduction
de la complexité du vivant en des
formules mathématiques
donc ça à mon avis c'est un premier
essai de quantifier tout ce qui est même
pas quantifiable et on parle de
quantification de mesures si vous voulez
des sentiments des comportements d
habitude et c'est ce qu'on fait quand on
est en ligne en permanence donc le
premier risque c'est de perdre un peu de
ce qui nous représente ce qui fait
naturel pour le confier à qui a des
algorithmes à des logiciels qui vont
tirer parti de cet apprentissage c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle qui vont apprendre de nous
deux de comportement de nos sentiments
pourquoi ferme pour nous mettre dans des
cases parce qu'on informatique on sait
très bien fait c'est faire des
arborescences et faire des box dans
lequel on va rentrer des comportements
alors pour moi le première prise de
risque avec cette informatisation qui va
vers automatisation rhdp tease à sion de
la société ces deux normes et tout ce
qui est même axe était impensable de
pouvoir normaliser quoi est de faire
rentrer des comportements dans des
habitudes et ça c'est un premier risque
lors cette prise de risque également
contre on va sur internet
à part le fait d'alimenter des systèmes
d'apprentissage qui vont nous dire
comment faire et ce qu'il faut
comprendre que plus on ça sera facile
pour nous plus on va se laisser
déposséder d'une façon de prendre des
décisions et c'est ce qui se fait avec
tous ses assistants électroniques qui
sont qui arrivent dans nos foyers dans
nos chambres à coucher pour pour nous
aider à nous faciliter la vie donc sous
cet apport du sans effort pour l'humain
de la facilitation de ce compagnonnage
veut c'est comme ça qu'on nous vend
la chaussée du compagnonnage on se
laisse déposséder de ce qui faisait
notre nature humaine c'est à dire un peu
notre un certain nos faiblesses nos
défaillances et puis la prise de
décision donc ça c'est un risque majeur
le deuxième risque qui est peut-être
aussi invisible c'est de celui de
comprendre que quand on délivre une
donnée sur internet qu une photo compose
d'un commentaire que l'on fait une
recherche que nous faisons sur un moteur
de recherche
c'est à peu près 20% des données que
nous laissons fac on est consciente
données d'une façon délibérée avec
laquelle on a donné notre consentement
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est 80%
80% des ces informations sont captés au
tour ce qu'on appelle les métadonnées
celle là où vous êtes avec l équipement
etc etc
donc c'est des données des métadonnées
et en plus avec ses algorithmes qui sont
omniprésents qui existe partout qui font
la richesse et la puissance de ses
acteurs hégémonique du net c'est des
données qui vont être calculé à partir
de données que vous allez laisser des
métadonnées donc on va nous mêmes
contribué à alimenter un système qui
nous dépasse et premier essai de perdre
là contre le contrôle de la vie cachée
de nos données celle qui nous que nous
connaissons mais toutes celles que nous
ignorons et celle que nous ignorons pour
les appeler notre empreinte digitale
notre double numérique et là il nous
échappe complètement il nous même quand
nous allons sur internet
puisqu'on est plutôt bienveillant et
bien on va donner plein de choses on va
dire on va pas forcément pensé la face
obscure de l'internet cette dualité et
on va se laisser déposséder de tout un
tas de ce qui fait notre nature humaine
nous on va devenir transparent tandis
que les multinationales pour les telles
qu'elles sauvent sont des
multinationales même si au départ il y
eut quelques startups comme eu des idées
géniales souvent ils ont été rachetés
bon elles vont manquer de transparence
il faut jamais nous donner les moyens de
savoir ce que sont ces données que nous
qui nous composent qu'elle ce qu'elles
sont font comment elles sont
commercialisées
comment ils sont traités et puis aussi
avec internet c'est la possibilité de
faire des rencontres merveilleuses mais
c'est aussi la menace d'un fort des
rencontres un peu moins agréable
pourquoi parce que tout et chacun peut
se connecter sur internet on va agir
caché derrière un écran
et puis à distance et là les mauvaises
confronte son potentiel et dans ses
mauvaises rencontres on peut parler
aussi de tout ce qu'ils vont conduire à
des escroqueries à des manipulations à
du harcèlement toutes sortes de fautes
sur lequel on
nous mêmes en tant qu'individu mais du
plus jeune au plus âgé être exposés et
dans cette population que nous sommes
d'internautes nous sommes aussi tous
exposés à la manipulation d'informations
à la désinformation
ce qui va nous conduire à prendre des
décisions qui seront qui aurait pu être
autre si on n'avait pas eu cette
information est trouvé ce qui est vrai
dans l'information sur internet est
complètement difficile à l'heure
actuelle et on doit prendre un risque d'
incroyable pour faire confiance à une
entité un serveur sur lequel on se
connecte toi une personne avec qui on
communique qui n'est peut-être pas la
personne qu'on croit qu'on souhaiterait
avec qui est en soi très communiqué
cette possibilité de fraude
d'escroquerie elle est énorme au niveau
des individus il ya plein d'armagh
sentimentale qui existent pour de jolies
avenir encore puisqu'on est assez naïve
on envie de croire aux côtés un petit
peu merveilleux de cette rencontre
et puis il ya des habile manipulateur ou
prédateur qui sont sur internet qui vont
chercher la faille et cette faille que
nous avons nous tous en tant qu'humain
passera aussi assez faciles à repérer du
fait que nous livrons beaucoup
d'informations parfois sur des réseaux
sociaux
donc les réseaux sociaux sont une mine
d'or pour montrer des escroqueries
contre des personnes individuelles mais
aussi au niveau des organisations ce
qu'on a vu apparaître ces derniers mois
et ces dernières années c'est tout ce
qui est prise en otage des ressources
informatiques pour effectuer des
chantages donc ça peut être des
chantages à la réputation mais c'est le
chantage au fait si on ne verse pas une
certaine rançon eh bien les données sont
perdues les systèmes sont bloquées et on
voit cette gradation des problèmes
possibles pour les individus mais aussi
pour les organisations mais aussi bien
sûr pour les états qui deviennent de
plus en plus dépendant de ses
infrastructures informatiques et
télécoms pour exister et toutes nos
infrastructures vitales que ce soit pour
l'énergie l'hôpital la finance dépendent
aussi de l'informatique
hélas ce qui est récent et qui pose de
la complexité qui dit complexité dit non
maîtrise c'est cette interdépendance de
ses infrastructures et tous les effets
domino qui peuvent qu on pourrait avoir
avec des risques en cascade avec des
impacts qui pourrait être catastrophique
alors cette prise de risque nous sommes
pas forcément conscient ne sommes pas
forcément des on a pas l'impression de
faire un sport de l'extrême quand on est
sur internet mais pourtant et pour
autant on pourrait à avoir des
vraiment catastrophique en tant
qu'individu sur notre vie humaine sur la
compétitivité économique des entreprises
et puis sur la souveraineté de l'état
donc des problèmes réels dont on
commence à prendre un petit peu
l'ampleur du problème et je pense pas
qu'on ait forcément les bonnes solutions
les façons de pouvoir gérer ça pourquoi
je dis ça c'est la vision que j'en ai
c'est que la techno qui est tellement
complexe on devient tellement dépendants
de cette technologie et on s'est
tellement peu la maîtrise et ont subi
des cyberattaques ont réagit parfois des
cyber attaques
regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
l'actualité enfin suffit d'ouvrir le
journal d'écouter la radio pour se
rendre compte à tous vulnérables à des
cyber attaques informatiques y compris
en suisse entre les virus et s'arrêtent
pas aux frontières
quand même ils se bougent un peu et en
fait on subit ces cyber-attaques on les
maîtrise pas ont subi cette évolution
technologique qu'on adapte parce qu'on
sait pas faire autrement parce qu'aussi
on nous fait croire qu'il n'ya pas
d'autre alternative et que cette
évolution technologique est une
évolution naturelle or c'est
complètement faux c'est pas une
évolution à la darwin les technologies
comme j'essayais de l'évoquer tout à
l'heure précédemment elles sont issues
d'un contexte culturel politique
économique particulière sont portés par
des acteurs compris étatiques alors en
fonction du fait qu'on maîtrise pas
cette technologie on a l'idée géniale de
se dire si on maîtrise pas la
technologie c'est pas grave on va
rajouter de la technologie pour
maîtriser de la technologie et on a
tendance à faire confiance à une
technologie qu'on maîtrise encore moi
qui ai aussi en plus d'autres problèmes
que générer problème est peut-être que
le risque principal quand on est dans
cet état d'esprit de technologie nation
d'un de la société ceux de penser que la
technologie va répondre à des problèmes
humains des problèmes économiques des
problèmes sociaux des problèmes
politiques et c'est faux ça va en
générer d'autres sa tête masquée
certains problèmes mais ça aura d'autres
problèmes donc cette fuite en avant
technologique et pour moi me semble-t-il
un risque majeur alors quels sont les
facteurs aggravants de cette prise de
risque c'est de penser que les
technologies sont vulnérables sont
friables
c'est on l'a dit c'est complexe mais non
seulement on n'a pas pensé cette
complexité en termes de sécurité on n'a
surtout pas pris en compte les besoins
voire les exigences de sécurité pour
avoir cet environnement de confiance et
c'est d'autant plus
que la sécurité de façon intuitive on
peut penser qu'elles coûtent cher en
termes de recherche de développement
d'implémentation de gestion et que
personne ne veut payer le coût de la
sécurité et j'irai même au delà en
disant que l'insécurité profite à
certains acteurs donc il n'ya pas de
sécurité il n'y a pas de ce qu'on dira
en anglais de security by design n'y a
pas de protection des données privées en
natif
pourquoi parce que tous les modèles
économiques de cette économie digital
est basée sur l'exploitation des données
donc tant qu'on change pas ce paradigme
des fondamentaux de l'économie numérique
on n'arrivera pas à protéger les données
les facteurs aggravants son set non
prise en compte des besoins de sécurité
cette fragilité des barrières de
sécurité quand elles existent tout les
toutes les solutions de sécurité ont été
cassées craqué et ont eu des effets
c'est préjudiciable sur la sécurité des
infrastructures donc une grande
difficulté pour assurer cette sécurité
qui est aussi doubler par le fait que
les malveillants ont très bien compris
comment faire du business avec cet
environnement digital de tirer profit de
cette insécurité et si l'information a
de la valeur pour les entreprises licite
a d'autant plus de valeur pour les
entreprises il ici tous les acteurs
malveillants qui veulent s'accaparer
cette richesse et à ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que dans cette infrastructure
numérique on a nos systèmes
d'information qui nous représente qui
sont des peut-être des symboles à
détruire et ça c'est la proche du monde
terroristes qui veulent détruire des
symboles notre économie qui sont étaient
représentées porté par l'internet
et puis c'est une source
d'enrichissement donc on est des cibles
on est devenus des cibles en ligne
connectés interdépendantes
ah ah enfin l'objet de cyber criminalité
de cyber attaques et cette population
d'acteurs qui peuvent être attractifs
actu peuvent être commandés à seynod si
nous sommes des cibles attractives pour
ces acteurs là ils ont su développer
toute une économie de cette malveillance
embarqués dans des logiciels puisque la
larme c du code informatique sus du
programme et c'est de l'information nous
est ce qu'on va retrouver tout ça sur
internet sur la face cachée de
l'internet nous en parlera de dark web
cette notion de noir et trous noirs tout
à l'heure on pourrait aussi faire le
lien et tout se vend et tout s'achète
sur internet y compris les compétences
et avec cet outil
de mise en relation des cibles et des
victimes des cibles et des valves ayant
est aussi de mise en relation de tous
tous les acteurs qui peuvent être
performant pour une malveillance données
donc tout ce qui est allouée à acheter
et c'est très facile d'être de devenir
malveillants sur internet ça sera
peut-être l'objet d'une autre conférence
met donc il ya tout un écosystème
favorable à cette à ces cyberattaques à
ces cyber malveillance qui sont
possibles sur internet
ce qu'on peut dire peut-être aussi en
termes de perspectives donc on a dressé
un panorama assez à ces normes et c'est
la notion de risque donc quels risques
voulons nous prendre maintenant sur
internet
sachant qu'on peut pas faire confiance
la confiance est pas possible non elle
est impossible dans les acteurs avec
lequel nous allons communiquer mais
impossible dans les technologiques nous
disons donc comment assurer ce niveau de
confiance et pourquoi peut-être la
question qu'il faudrait peut-être se
poser c'est pourquoi nous allons donner
nos vies sur internet alors que rien et
maintenant c'est connu rien n'est fiable
et sécurisée ni sécurisable dans le
temps ce quand on branche un téléphone
sur internet ou un objet connecté sur
internet c'est pas l'objet que nous
branchons c'est nos vies qui est que
nous penchons sur internet donc se poser
la question jusqu'où j'ai envie de
prendre un risque pour un service qui
peut me divertir qui peux m'amuser
qui peut me rendre service qui peuvent
faciliter la vie mais qu'est-ce que je
donne en échange quelle est ma monnaie
les changes est là où les acteurs de
l'internet sont très forts c'est qu'ils
ont su faire de l'argent avec du gratuit
ça veut dire qu'on est on est donné les
produits quand même et le slogan pour
était de transformer la data en or et la
connectivité en pouvoir je pense que
tant qu'on n'aura pas pris conscience de
l'importance de ce slogan marketing qui
est porté par ces acteurs hégémonique du
net on prendra pas suffisamment la prise
de risque pris en se livrant comme ça
sans fin nous donner se pose est
peut-être la question de savoir est ce
que pour accepter cette nouvelle
application qui peux m'amuser une grande
service est ce que j'ai besoin de donner
tout accès à tous mes contacts à tous
mes contenus que je trouve sur mon
périphérie donc essayer d'avoir des
réflexes de base de ce repos se
réapproprier notre écosystème notre vie
et se poser la question de l'intérêt de
l'utilité de cette connectivité de ces
données
et puis peut-être
je crois qu'il pourrait oser prendre le
risque de transformer tout ce qui est
progrès scientifiques et technologiques
en progrès social économique et
politique
ça c'est un risque j'ai envie de prendre
en revanche le risque j'ai surtout pas
envie de prendre ses connaissances tout
ce qu'on connaît maintenant de cette
technologie de cette vulnérabilité et de
ses dangers porté par ces technologies
ces menaces
franchement j'ai pas envie de prendre le
risque d'être banni par les générations
futures
ce choix est maintenant peut plus dire
qu'on ne savait pas et donc c'est à nous
tous ensemble de contribuer à bâtir cet
écosystème numérique de définir les
règles du jeu de savoir ce qui est
acceptable ou pas en fonction de notre
culture de notre vision du monde et de
ce qu'on a envie de laisser en héritage
à nos enfants
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]